- I am amazingly grateful
for this moment
to be introduced to my great friend.
The most incredible, brilliant actress
that I've had an opportunity
to work with, is special,
(audience clapping)
Alfre Woodard.
As Sam Jackson
stood and talked about his work,
I remember Sam Jackson and myself
were in a play reading
at the Frank Sivero Workshop in New York.
And who was directing that play reading?
Morgan Freeman, 1980.
One of the incredible things
about receiving such an award
is what to say.
The many speeches that I had planned,
this whole presentation was
my speech I think in some way.
But outside of that,
I respect and I'm honored by the Academy
to present me with the
Jean Hersholt Award.
And, at this particular moment in time,
we can think about our past,
we can remember our past.
But one of the things
that I've come through
through my wonderful grandparents
who didn't allow their daughters and son
to pick cotton in September,
and sent them to school in September.
And because of that,
these heroic, amazing people
in Louisville, Georgia,
she was, in fact, only the first person
to graduate from college in her
family and in her community.
And she inspired me,
my mother, because no one worked harder,
no one dreamed harder,
and no one just fought for justice.
My mother was the regional president
of the National Council of
Negro Women in San Francisco.
Her chapter raised more
money than any chapter
in the country for the
Mary McLeod Bethune statue,
which stands outside of
the organization's building right there.
My dad, the most incredibly
beautiful man that I ever met,
falling in love with him
when I was five years old.
An endless dream that was never separated
in that period of time till
he took his last breath.
I listened to the amazing
Liv Ullmann.
(audience clapping)
Just the feeling to be on,
at this stage, and to stand with her,
it's just amazing.
It's just one of the
great memories of my life.
Like her movies,
were one of the great
memories of my life as well.
When you wanted to think about
what are the things you wanna
do in front of the camera?
Having no idea that I would ever be
in front of the camera at that time.
And what are some of the
feelings, universal feelings,
that she's displayed that
went beyond just Sweden,
but carried us through our development
in this part of human development as well?
Those are things that happened.
The opportunity to work with Alfre Woodard
on "Mandela" and other
cases in other places.
The opportunity to work with her
has been one of the great
pleasures in my career.
To have so much
incredible energy, and incredible wisdom,
and an incredible love for what she does,
and for humanity, has been incredible.
I've also had a rich relationship
with organized labor.
As I said before,
if it's mentioned here,
my mother and father,
James and Carrie Glover,
came at a point in time
when the labor movement in San Francisco
gave them a sense of purpose,
raising a family and having the sense
that they were in that bridge,
they were connected to a larger
story, a larger narrative.
I have here with me, a
great friend of mine,
George Gresham,
who is the president
and executive director
right here of SEIU 1199 in New York.
One of the great, great, great.
(audience clapping)
And you would know that artists had a home
in 1199, historically,
with bread and roses.
I'm here, there in celebrating this,
'cause this belongs to them.
This belongs to the
workers that I had a chance
to sit with and to support
as they walked out on their
work for great justice
and a better working place in
the country where they were.
I had the opportunity to
work with Bruce Raynor.
Bruce Raynor, who brought me to Mexico,
where we sat on the floor
of a woman making $30 a week
trying to feed her family,
and have just a few of her seven kids
go to school.
Bruce Raynor has been an extraordinary
part of my life,
as he allowed me to sit in the back rooms
and sometimes to make the tough decisions
that have to be made to make
this a better workplace.
And then, also a better world as well.
Those are the ones whose
gifts that have been given me
in this particular moment, and in life,
and throughout that life.
That strike of 1968, which began
as the Black Student Union,
which created the Third World Coalition
of African American,
Latino American,
Asian American, and white Americans
to talk about the truth aversion
of the 1619 Project of
critical race theory.
(audience clapping)
And how do you get here?
How do you get to this point?
How do you move and keep moving?
It's because people move
and they continue to move.
I am proud of being a part of that.
And I'm proud of being someone
who was moved by the work of Athol Fugard
in South Africa and his writings.
Which Zakes Mokae,
a wonderful South African actor,
Zakes Mokae took me around
to the homes and parties
that South Africans, exiled, would have
in San Francisco and the Bay Area.
And somewhere about midnight,
they began to have the music
of their homeland.
The speaking about homeland,
the tears and pain of being exiled here
not knowing what the future is
at their homelands.
And those stories moved us, moved me.
And I was happy to be a part of that.
If I seem repetitive in my comments,
it's because I didn't know
that my speech was going to be here.
(audience laughing)
And so I haven't referred to this,
the teleprompter, at all,
because I don't.
(audience clapping)
And sometimes we, as actors,
become a little lost if
we don't have a script.
(audience laughing)
It brings us alive here.
As I've said,
with Samuel L. Jackson, Liv Ullmann,
and those who have graced our screens,
and those who continue,
I'm proud to be a part
of this space and place.
And thank you, thank you,
thank you, thank you.
(audience clapping)